α τον καρκοινο τουμαστού πιο μήνυμα θέλει να στείλει οι στέλλα κυριακήδου στις γυναίκες που
βλέπουν σήμερα αυτό τον πότας να μη χάνουν ποτέ τον το στόχον του την ελπίδα
τους ότι είμαστε δίπλα τους και ότι οι ώσες είναι τώρα μέσα σε αυτή την
τον κυκαιώ να μπονομάζεται θεραπεία και διάγνωση δεν είναι μόνες είναι δύσκολος δρόμος δεν των
οραιοποιούμε αλλά πάντα υπάρχει κάποιο εκύπουν μπορεί να ταστηρίξη και στ στης γυρόπατο κύπρου που
είναι για τον καρκοινοτούμαστού είναι πάντα κάποι εκύπουν μπορεί να τεστη ρίξη και κι είνες
και τις οικογένειες τους θέλα πάμε λίγο σε ένα άλλο θέμα ποανήξαμε σε ότι αφρατών
λίβανο κατά α γίνονται αυτές τις μέρες πολύ ανάγκη αποφάρμακα μια ασθενής υπάττο κι εναι
και να έτοιμα ίσως υπάρξει και άλλοι εμπλοκι από πλέβρά σας το διάστην απόσας σθεμένοι
λόγο και της κατάστασης που ίναικαείείναι καθημερι οι επαφή που χουμε το άλλο μεγάλο κομμάτι
της πανδημίας ήταν η ανάγκη να εργαζόμαστε σε παγκόσμο επίπεδο δεν μπορείς και από τότε
επο έχομια εξθρετική συνεργασία με τον παγκόσμιο οργανισμόύ γίας και με τον πογκόσμε ουργανισμόύ γείας
ιδικά το τμήμα που αφορά τη ευρώπι που ασχολείται με τα θέματα της τη γάζας
του λιβάνου και τα λοιπά είναι πολύ στσθενή επαφή που έχουμε για να δούμε ακριβώς
ποιες είναι ανάγκες παριδείγματος χάρι μόλις είχαμε δύ ότι υπήρχε ανάγκη για να προχωρήσουν σε
μια ετρατια εμβολιασμού για την πολιομελίτηδα εγώ είχα επικοινονήσει μαζί με τον πο κόσμε ουργανισμο
ηγίας και αυτά τα κάνοκατευθεί ανδηλαδή έχων τα τηλέφωνα παίρνω συνεργάτες πια που έχουμε περάσειτ
μαζί τι υπανδιμία και